welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast i'm your
host hisham azuz and in this week's
episode i sat down with karen deep soho
who is the founder of a company called
pivot search it was the first person we
had from leeds in the podcast studio and
after a decade of working for other
people karen deep over the last two
years has been on a journey in building
his very own recruitment business and
the real theme of this episode which i
absolutely loved and dug into a lot of
detail on
is why karen deep is so passionate about
building a recruitment business that
prioritizes its people over profits
the cynicals out there will say what
you're on about you need to be making
money and those things and uh absolutely
and i really go into detail with karen
deep about what does that actually mean
prioritizing people over profits what
does that look like within the company
what are some of the things that he's
investing in how is he supporting his
teams and how is that impacting
performance are they making more money
are they performing better we just
discuss it all in this episode and i
really hope you enjoy it
karen deep welcome to the podcast hi
thanks for having me jim thank you so
much for uh making the trip
uh from leeds yep again we had last time
i was in here we had the first irishman
in in the studio now we've got the first
yorkshire good to be representing the
north
exactly so really excited for this i
guess just to frame it out for everyone
listening i'm just talking about this so
you've had a really long time in the
recruitment industry over a decade
before you started your own sort of
entrepreneurial journey so we are gonna
touch a little bit on i guess what you
learnt in that period but we're really
going to focus on today your journey as
a recruitment entrepreneur building your
your recruitment business pivot and
really talk about the things that you're
passionate about and why you're really
committed to building a recruitment
business that's that's genuinely
different
so i guess where i always like to start
though is is the million pound question
the question that you've probably really
thought long and hard about when hiring
for your business
so i'd love to hear sort of your
thoughts and takes on what you believe
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant in today's market the traits
the the common uh things that you see in
uh successful people today cool i think
it's a really interesting question to
start with but also you know there's the
stereotypical answers that
you expect you know you're looking for
somebody driven committed tenacious
resilient you know you hear those words
all the time but
for me it's actually i think the the
thing that differentiates good
recruiters
from the average or the very good from
the good is actually mindset and
attitude and ambition
and what you find what i find is that
i consider myself a successful recruiter
but i've also managed a lot of
successful
recruiters in the past and still do and
i think yes they have those traits but
what makes them different is mindset and
attitude and i think the thing that
stands out is
a lot of very good recruiters
know what they want to achieve and then
have the reason behind it and what you
find is what they want to achieve is
quite ambitious it tends to reflect what
is actually the best version of
themselves what is the best of me and
that's where they set the benchmark
that's what i want to achieve and
they're very
committed determined in that's what i
want to achieve when you start to talk
to them they have a reason why and the
why is always different you know
traditionally a lot of people tell you
will people just do recruitment for
money well you know yeah they do but
there are other reasons you get to
understand why and suddenly
what you find is with the more
successful recruiters they have a very
clear picture of what they want to
achieve they have a good reason why
they go they're quite ambitious and
driven they want to do it and your job
as a leader is actually to do the how
you know i love that you're there to
give them the resources the tools the
advice the support
you know the shoulder to do that but
ultimately the bit that you
find very difficult to influence is the
what do you want to achieve and why i
think
a lot of recruitment leaders just
walk out of target meetings going yeah
look we've got them hyped up they want
to achieve this they walk out and go
no actually i don't want i've got no
real
they walk out and it disappears but the
really good people are telling you this
is what i want to achieve this is why i
want to do it
you give me the how and that's the
difference having those people who quite
clearly know what they want to achieve
they're focused ambitious
and they really want to do it that's the
difference you've really got to
believe in what you want to achieve and
why you want to do it and
what you find is a large percentage of
the time they go on to do that because
they're driving it not being told
i love that so
just on this very quickly i'm interested
to get your thoughts on this so like you
said as a leader you'd struggle to
influence the the why and the sort of
picture of what they want to achieve and
your job there is to facilitate the how
and educate on that so i guess for
people listening and i don't know if you
did this for yourself and maybe you help
your your team now but like what good
quality questions can we ask ourselves
to unpack that and uncover
uh what the sort of why is or what it is
that we want to achieve because i think
a lot of these things can come from good
questions and asking ourselves good
questions so what might be some some
good questions that we can ask ourselves
that can help us arrive at what is it
that i want and why
i think the key to it is not
sitting in a meeting and presenting
those questions like you can win to meet
and go right
what do you want to achieve because
you're going to get a surface level
answer that hasn't had much thought what
you actually want to do is
empower your consultants and
make sure you're prepping them for the
times you want to take time out to
understand what they want to achieve
give them sort of questions what you
know asking them what do you really want
to achieve
and ask them why what what are the
drivers but then actually go on to say i
don't just want you to write down what
you're trying to achieve i actually want
you to go away write down what you want
to achieve but what does it look like
what visually you know you achieving
your goals what's it look like but then
go deeper what does it feel like because
once you know only something like five
percent of people achieve their targets
if they just write them down
something like 25 to 30 percent of
people achieve their targets if they
visualize them what does it look like
but it's something like 60 to 70 percent
of people achieve their targets when
they can actually write them down
picture them
and
feel the emotion of achieving that
target that's actually getting an
emotional buy-in um
and that isn't just coming from me
making that up we've actually worked um
part of our development program is
working with
one of the best um
coaches who's worked with some
amazing sports stars businesses on
achieving the best in yourself and to
achieve the best in yourself you have to
you don't have to just write it it's
about writing it seeing it feeling it
and
that is how you do it so it's difficult
to say what particular questions you
know i think you've answered that it's
like i think a good framework there is
yeah firstly what is it that you you
want
visually what what is it that that you
yeah you see happening or how you want
to see it and then yeah the important
question on like how's that going to
make you feel i think that's a great
little framework that people can use but
i think the bit that i'd add is you've
got to take away the fear of
consultants coming in or employees
coming in and telling you what you they
feel you want to hear right you've got
to let them say there are no boundaries
there are no
parameters of you've got to stay in this
you know you should feel comfortable
saying whatever reason people may have
the most ridiculous things of what they
want to achieve and why they want to but
they shouldn't feel you know embarrassed
or feared coming into his meeting to
tell you you know if that's what drives
them
great you know they shouldn't
feel like we can't say that or not
that you want to hear yeah that's a
great point thank you for having that
okay so
i guess i just have one question for you
a lot of recruiters listen to this who
are aspiring to be in the top 10 of
their business
want to have the best possible
recruitment career they can
so obviously before you started pivot
you worked um
for a couple of different brands over
over just over a decade and from what i
saw on on linkedin on both occasions you
got to the head of position so i guess
in hindsight what i'd just be good just
to get your thoughts on an anecdote on
is like looking back what is it that you
think you did
that enabled you to to get to that point
and i guess just any sort of thoughts or
um
notes on for people listening to this
who really want to maximize the
opportunity they have in an employer
that's going to give them the
progression opportunities that could
enable them to get to that head of
position
for people listening yeah so thoughts on
how how can people really maximize the
opportunity they have in a recruitment
company and how you think you did that i
think that probably the first thing i'd
talk about is actually
don't be afraid to be pushed out of your
comfort zone when i first stepped into
management um
probably just over 10 years ago it came
about in a real unexpected fashion um
it's quite a funny story my manager at
the time was working for a business that
wasn't particularly performing well my
manager went into a management meeting
was supposed to go out
on a work football trip taking a team to
germany ceo asked them do you really
think should be going and
he um died and went yeah i think we
should go and ceo obviously thought
differently and
decided that's a time for a management
change and
came to me and said well i want you to
head up that oil and gas division and
sat there looking going
[ __ ] i don't have not managed before i'm
two three years into my career you know
and it's not i wouldn't say it's
necessarily been
a lightning start to recruitment but i
was pushed out my comfort zone and given
the reassurance that actually
you can do it give it a go what what is
the worst
that can happen you know and i think
that is really important that at times
you'll be pushed out of your comfort
zone i think
you've got to take those opportunities
but also on the proviso that
there is the support and reassurance
there that actually
yet we're pushing you out but we will
support you we will make
it as comfortable as experience as
possible and
i think don't be afraid to step out of
your comfort zone is really important
but also
you've got to embrace change evolution
you've got to be
flexible
you know the longer you're stuck in your
ways and fail to adapt to the team that
you're managing the people that you're
managing the harder it is because
one thing i've found is you've
constantly got to be thinking about well
what's working right that's brilliant
but what not necessarily what's not
working but
what could i what can we do better how
can we evolve to continue moving forward
and i think that's got to be the mindset
of a good
manager a good leader is somebody who is
prepared to try things but also prepared
to accept that not everything you try
is going to work so how do you make it
work you don't give up on it um
i'd say they're really important traits
that have helped me get to
where i am
and also i think it's really important
to to listen to the people around you
not just the people above you but the
people that you manage you've got to
really understand your team i think
probably in the last
i'd say
certainly in the last couple of years of
pivot you was actually a core value of
ours but
the length to which i actually
understand my staff get to know my staff
helps me actually manage them so that
they get the best out of themselves so
you know don't think that as a manager
as a leader it's just about shouting
orders out and
actually
handing out tasks and telling people to
do things it's also about
understanding your team and
understanding they are individuals in
fact working out how do you get the best
out of different people because there is
definitely no one-size-fits-all policy
no i love that some great things in
there so yeah leaning into
getting out of your comfort zone leaning
into opportunities that you get given
and sort of trusting that
you'll uh yeah hopefully thrive or at
least yeah lead into the opportunities
that you get yeah i love the point
around uh just yeah being really
open-minded to how you've done things in
the past and how things could maybe
evolve and change and that yeah just
just be a really good listener and i
guess just don't think you know it all
yeah so yeah i love that so i guess
let's go into your entrepreneurial then
so i guess what where i'd like to start
is because look i know how passionate
you are about building a brand that's
generally different okay and i guess
where i wanted to start was a lot of
people start their recruitment
businesses by saying we're going to do
it differently
how many people actually do it
differently not sure very very few yeah
so i i wanted to just get your first
take on like again just thinking about
your past experiences what is it that
you took from those experiences
um pros and cons that you're like right
i'm going to take these parts i'm not
going to do these parts and these are
the things that i'm going to make sure i
deliver on in in pivot and why i think
obviously a lot of people will take all
these different experiences so you know
what i really like what they did there
i'm definitely not going to do that so
just just keen to get your initial
thoughts when you thought about your
business what were the things that you
are really going to commit to
um and what are the things that you you
definitely wanted to avoid and it'd be
just good to understand why
that you would have taken from these
different experiences that you had i
think the big commitment from my side
was
i'm gonna do this i'm gonna be a
genuinely different search firm and i am
going to do it i think the most
important thing is it comes from the
leadership it comes from me if i don't
champion it if i don't embrace it i
don't practice it it won't happen
um and i think the other important thing
for me was i i
as well as taking the good bits and i
think that's something that i've done
probably
certainly over the last
six seven eight years is actually work
out what are the good bits what are the
bits worth keeping what are the bits
worth investing in and making better but
i think probably what's more influential
is
learning
people talk about learning from my
mistakes but i'd actually talk about
learning more from my experiences i
worked in recruitment 15 years ago when
you know
it was a very stereotypical industry you
know people were the three-piece suits
the pinstripe suits it was a bit boiler
room wolf of wall street
micromanaged blanket kpis and
you've got to learn from that experience
and go well what doesn't work and i
think that's got to be a big driver he's
not looking at what the mistakes that i
made but what was it i didn't like what
what was it that do you know what in the
modern day workplace doesn't work so
what were some of those things there um
i'd say micromanagement yeah um you know
ever and micromanagement's just blanket
kpis everybody has to do the same number
of e-shots everybody has to make the
same number of calls
we used to have phone times when i first
started um
which to be honest were the biggest
waste of time ever because
the people at the top you know got a
bottle of wine at the end of each week
but also people were sat ringing the
talking clock or their mum on a friday
afternoon just to get to that
level but i think the big things are
that there was a big culture where
people
or sorry employees of the business were
just treated like revenue generating
cogs in a machine they weren't treated
as people and i think it's really really
important to treat people
as people value them as people you know
there wasn't a culture or a mentality to
be able to talk about mental health
there certainly was no support for
mental health
at that point or consideration for it it
was literally you come to work do the
job or you get shouted at um
there wasn't an investment in technology
there wasn't
you know
it there was zero flexibility you know
you worked 60 70 hour weeks and do you
know what if you didn't cut the mustard
you were made to feel like [ __ ] and
openly in front of the office you'd be
chastised and
you know all of that experience you look
at it and go well
i went through that
and
do you know what
it wasn't good for me it wasn't good for
many people in the business it certainly
didn't bring the best out of people so
they're the things that i'm going to
push out and
also the way that businesses were led
you know
and i think still to this day there are
businesses like that where you know the
recruitment owners
cream the profits they drive around in
the ferraris and you know
the people in the top of the business
get the holidays and the incentives but
do you know what the people who are
doing well achieving what they should be
achieving in the middle of are left and
forgotten and you talk to people in
these businesses and they're like you
know
blanket kpis micromanagement still
exists and
do you know what people love you if you
hit your targets and you're doing well
but if not
you're made to feel like dirt and
you could be the top biller in the
business but you might have missed
target last month or blank last month
and you're still made to feel like crap
it's very short-termistic view of
managing people i think
the way that i managed now is largely
influenced by the things that previous
leaders and managers
did badly as opposed to did well
thank you for sharing that so i guess
this is this let's start them with
obviously you've got it um on your
website you obviously make it very clear
on on linkedin around the you very much
like you said value people over profit
so let's just obviously i do feel like
and i know i told you about this that
there's some
more and more i feel recruitment
companies are um are leading with that
approach
some people were cynical about it um in
terms of hearing that's like okay what
do you actually do so i guess it'd be
good just to hear your thoughts on that
okay when you actually say that how does
that actually manifest in your business
and in the context of a recruitment
business when you say we value people
over profit
what does that actually mean give us
some examples of you yeah the things
that you you think that sort of really
demonstrate that
i think to start with
from the leadership you've got to buy
into yeah you've got to believe it
you've got to believe live it's going to
come from you it's authentic it can't
just be like we're doing this because
it's going to make us different 100 yeah
there's a lot of businesses that market
themselves as something you go and work
for them and they're not so that's rule
number one you actually practice what
you preach you say what you do
from you the leadership team everyone
yeah yeah definitely um but the way that
we've broken it down is i i looked at
the first question i asked myself is
you know
before i look at what i want to change
why do i want to change it because for
me
it's time for recruitment to evolve
break the stereotypes the stigmas that
we've just talked about that still exist
and
i think the first thing to do is a
change of mindset as a leader
a lot of recruitment leaders are fixated
on
where people work when people work um
and
for me we've moved away from that my
mindset is actually on the deliverables
let's look at what people want to
achieve my conversation
with any consultant joining the business
um at the beginning of the year at the
half point in the year what do you want
to achieve and
you know there's got to be a mutuality
agreement that we want to achieve below
above a certain point
but ultimately
you know once you tell me you want to
achieve that
i'm actually fixated on helping you
achieve that i'm not fixated on where
you work when you work what you do with
your
working day so flexibility is a massive
thing for me so we operate a system of
working
when you want to work
so
that's seven days a week you can work
when you want if you prefer to work on a
sunday as opposed to friday go do it you
know where you work does it matter
whether you're working in an office does
it matter whether you're working from
home does it matter that you're working
from a coffee shop you could be working
on a holiday you know
i had somebody ask me well i want to go
to south america if i get
a um airbnb can i work from south
america for three months and i said well
you know as long as you won't realize
you are working go for it
you know and
why should it matter when you work the
hours you work you know it should
actually be about the deliverables it
should be
certainly about the fact that let's
focus on you achieving what you want to
achieve and move away from being fixated
on those things
and
i think innovation is really really
important and
i'd start by talking
innovatively managing people you know
the way in which i
believe is the right way to doing things
is giving people you know trust autonomy
flexibility which three three of our
core values and living by them so
i catch up with people on a monday and i
want to catch up as a person
not what business have you got what
revenues coming in what you're doing
this week in terms of kpis how's your
weekend what have you been up to you
want to understand people it enables you
to support people if you actually
can engage with them and then
you know what do you want to achieve for
the week right my job's to support you
but i'm going to let you go get on with
it
but i'm here to support you whether it's
something little you know you might be
frustrated with the search and you know
you're at the end of your tether with it
just all you need to do is drop me a
message and go caz can i have some help
with this
it could be a bigger issue it could be
you know a process that's got issues it
could be a client that's being difficult
you know but
you've got to be approachable as a
manager but
what you find is that if people are
approaching you for a call
and saying this it actually matters to
them and you're not having to
micromanage the hell out of them i don't
there is no benefit in me ringing them
every morning every afternoon
you know
a lot of those meetings are pointless we
don't do them and i find people are more
productive
from an innovative perspective i really
want to move forward instead of
you know traditionally when consultants
position themselves to clients and
candidates how are you a specialist oh
well i've placed with companies a b and
c and um i've filled roles x y and z i
can't put them together for
confidentiality and also
they're a bit made up whereas i actually
want to change the way that recruiters
market themselves and make them genuine
key people of in influence influence and
the way
that requires an investment it comes
back to prioritizing people over profits
you can't
prioritize people without compromising
something and that's profitability
because i'm investing in them i'm
putting money into them so making people
keep people of influence where they're
genuinely increasing their credibility
their visibility their reputation in the
market so
when the client says well how are you a
key person influence well
let me show you some of the marketing
collateral that i've produced in your
market talking to your peers your
competitors people in your business
about what's going in your market i can
genuinely show that
i'm deeply embroiled in the market and
people in the market directors vp senior
level management are prepared to create
collateral put their name put their
company's name to it
and that's how i'm a key person of
influence you know as opposed to the
answer that you've been taught for 10 15
years um
but also making sure that people have
the tools you know we are a smaller
business but
i'm not afraid to invest in tech as long
as
it has a reason it has a purpose and it
adds
value so
one of the ways that we've really
maximized this is pi partnering with
businesses instead of
you're a supplier to me you supply
product xyz that's it
we actually treat our suppliers as
partners we'll work with them to
maximize the benefit and they're deeply
bought into us because
you know we'll provide them all the
testimonials in the world because
they're doing a great job for us
but equally as much they're helping the
consultants maximize it so
having a tech stack that actually
delivers value internally and externally
is how we're innovative and
i think the other piece that
is really important is that we've
created a culture and an environment
that really embraces mental health and
you know it's not just about providing
support you've got to have an
environment where
employees feel comfortable talking about
mental health you know recruitment puts
a lot of strain on you and
you are a person not an employee you
know there are things going on at home
in people's lives that have a massive
strain on the mental health they can't
have a button or a switch that turns it
off when they walk in the office
and
we've created an environment where if
you talk about mental health i'm not
saying openly to the whole business on
slack i'm having a tough time but come
to me and talk about mental health i'm
not going to put a mark against their
name and go oh [ __ ] you know what we're
gonna have to manage them out you know
i'm gonna have to watch out it's
actually right
let's help them let's support them let's
you know give them the empathy that they
deserve and understanding that you know
this thing's going on how can i help you
how can i support you but going on
beyond that we actually use a
third-party partner who is
an employee well-being practitioner they
provide confidential advice people can
ring them i don't necessarily know who
rings them unless people tell me and
they have professional advice so
sometimes it gets to a point where
people come to me and i'm pushing them
on saying
i don't know quite what the answer is
and i don't i think it's too important
to second guess the answer
go on to our mental health practitioner
speak to them talk to them don't worry
we'll we'll pay for that but i want to
make sure you're okay but it all starts
from having that culture
it's okay to not be okay it's okay to
talk about mental health and i think
what we've done is we've packaged it up
as an employee offering that isn't just
about
you know flexibility that isn't just
about innovation that isn't about
well-being it's actually about a
complete employee offering without
compromise you know
the other thing we had to think about is
people do the job for money we wanted to
have the strongest commission structure
that's actually achievable that isn't
just on paper looks good but impossible
to achieve in practice so
that is how we are different that we
offer a lot to employees but they know
they're not compromised they can
literally
achieve more money with pivot than they
can anywhere else right so let's couple
things we're going to go into thank you
for sharing all that so i want to i just
the fir the first thing is let me i'll
just ask you the direct question i was
going to ask you that i had that
obviously you sort of make it clear that
you have one of the the best commission
structures out there what is that so
we've got a commission structure where
you can take home
45
upwards
of your revenue generating total
earnings so making that clear that's
your basic salary commission and bonus
we don't have any time parameters on
that so we don't stick four-week period
limitations quarterly limitations
half-year limitations it's quite simple
if you generate the revenue you will
take home commission take home great
earnings you know there are not there
are very few if any 150k billers who
earn 68k
very basically depending on what you
bill you take 45
no so you have your basic salary and
then you have your
commission
based around your basic salaries it is
also a very fair structure so
you can look at two two people who are
sat next to each they can look at each
other if they both built 200k they both
know they've earned 94k right if they've
written 250k they've earned 120. okay
so
there is a little bit of change in the
early parts the commission structure
depending on your base
but
overall when you come to the end of the
year you will have taken home 45 plus
of what you've earned compared to the
traditional
30 33 hey everyone a real quick one from
me this podcast would not be possible
without our amazing podcast partners
vincerie and sauce breaker because you
listen to this podcast you're able to
get your hands on exclusive savings on
both of these award-winning products if
you're all a growing recruitment
business you have to check out vincerie
who are an all-in-one operating system
for your growing recruitment business
with sauce breaker if you want to make
sure that all of your recruiters have
the best tools on the market to stand
out and beat their competition then you
have to check out sourcebreaker use the
link in the show notes in the comments
below and you'll be able to get yourself
exclusive savings on these amazing
products yeah it depends okay thanks for
sharing that so then the other thing i
just want to play sort of um
not devil's advocate but i feel like
people listening and might be wondering
this particular leader so all the things
that you shared there amazing i think
kudos to you to committing to that and
really living and buy it so
i really understand the focus on
outcomes and deliverables totally
understand that so i guess what i wanted
to ask you was
like where where's the line ultimately
so like if you have someone where you've
decided what the the target is for the
year
and you check in at the the halfway
point and and they're quite a way off
i guess what i wanted to get your
thoughts on is like how do you how do
you sort of stay close to the line of
light yes we're going to give them
autonomy trust that's what we're leading
with
we're going to focus on the outcomes but
what sort of things do you keep an eye
on and stay close to that could
potentially be markers of like this
person isn't isn't quite up to where
they need to be
um that is going to be required to help
for them to achieve the outcome that
they're after do you know what i mean so
like again there might be specific
activities that you might be looking out
for i guess i wanted to just get your
thoughts on that's great you trust them
but there will be things that you're
looking at and and paying close
attention to because surely you're going
to have to do that to be confident that
these people are really maximizing their
trust autonomy in the environment that
you've built so what are some of the
things that you look at and stay close
to absolutely it's really important i
think you'd be naive not to ask that
question because
not everything goes amazingly to plan
and i think the big the first question
to ask yourself is why oh well i don't
ask myself the question i'll ask them
why why why are you where you are at the
moment okay what what's you know what
you feel isn't quite going right what do
you feel could help and support you
but equally as much i think the big
thing for me is
is attitude do you know
if somebody is really championing
embracing the values showing commitment
to the business and showing that you
know what
i appreciate that it's not quite where i
need to be or where i'd like to be
but
i'm working hard i'm committed i'm
listening to you and i'm putting into
place what we are trying to help you how
we're supporting you but what are the
tangibles on that because like that's
quite how do you how do you how can you
recognize do you know what i mean how do
what are some of the short are you
looking at first stage interviews being
booked i don't know there's got to be
some tangibles in there that give you
that confidence it depends what what's
going wrong if if it's
you know a lack of vacancies so i'd
be keeping in touch with that person and
i'd talk them through well
it's not let's not just look at
vacancies get more vacancies let's
actually break it down let's go beneath
the service what do you need to do to
get more vacancies how can we be
innovative how can we think outside of
the box we're challenged to get more
vacancies and these are the things that
i think we need to be looking at right
and naturally say look like
let's set your wins for a week or a
period or a quarter or a half year
focusing on this let's don't focus on
the end goal let's
move away from focusing on revenue
ultimately revenue is the end goal i get
that but
you know if you're fixated on revenue
but you're not doing the right things
beneath the service let's try and get
those right
and what's important to me is if
somebody goes away and really works hard
at that and he's doing the right things
he's coming back to me and saying well
this is working that's not working
you know what you're likely to help them
and support them to get there but
equally as much if people
don't have the commitment
and don't have the attitude and don't
embrace the values of the business and
quite frankly they're telling you i
don't care they're the people that
you're having conversations of
you know i don't think pivot's probably
the right place for you because you're
not going to achieve your goals and
you know your part of the jigsaw in the
business isn't going to be achieved and
yeah that's not fair on me but that's
not found the rest of the business sure
the rest of the business who are either
achieving their goals exceeding their
goals or making sure they're doing
everything to get as close to their
goals as possible
why should they be held back and have to
ask the question well what's so and so
doing in the business and that's the
important thing you know yes when things
don't go to plan
we put things right we've i've got bags
of experience have taken so many people
in the past through challenging times
you know recruitment is notorious it has
its eyes but it has its lows
if people are willing to be supported
take that on board
and actually put in the commitment the
hard work that takes you back to the
highs
great i'm all for it but
you know if you're just on the pivot
ride for a good basic salary and
quite frankly sticking two fingers up at
the rest of the business
you know unfortunately you're not right
i think
and and that goes that extends beyond
what i look for in a consultant it's not
just
revenue you know you could have a
350 400k builder but if they're
completely disruptive and
stick two fingers up at the
culture
yeah you know they're no matter what
their revenue is it's actually
destructive to the business and that's
probably as destructive as you're
more destructive than you're under
performer yeah you're under former if
you people look at them and go
i can see they're doing it they're more
likely to pull in support from the team
you know i'll help you
whereas the person who doesn't care do
you know what people will push and push
them away and go i'm not wasting my time
there okay so i just want to frame this
up for people listening because and then
a couple of a couple questions so
so how this i know this isn't all about
uh revenue but i think it's important
for people to see how this is sort of
played out so i've got here when we
prepared for this office a year um end
of year one ended around the sort of
650k revenue mark because of six of you
obviously you're on your uh when's the
end of your second year september so
we've got last quarter of the year last
quarter last quarter of the year um
should be finishing on eight people or
eight people today yep yeah and then on
track to do one to 1.2 million turnover
right
so what i wanted to ask you there's a
couple of things just around this to as
we come to the end here so
i guess firstly you've been really
positive about it and these things so um
the question i asked you first is with
this approach with this intention around
the type of recruitment business you
want to build and the type of people you
want to employ and support what have
been
in in these two years what have been the
biggest challenges with that approach
that maybe you under you didn't
anticipate
yeah talk to us about some of the
challenges with this because some some
people listen to this may want to
approach it like this
and really like intend to
grow a culture like this within their
recruitment business but and maybe have
concerns or worried about certain things
so what have been some of the biggest
challenges that maybe you didn't plan
for i think probably the biggest
challenge that i didn't plan for is
people not believing what we say we do
we deliver on
that a lot of people when i market pivot
externally to consultants
they'll ask them ask me well it's too
good to be true you know i've been
earning
approximately a third of what i generate
in revenue and you're telling me that i
can increase my
earnings by 20 or 30 grand that's a hell
of a lot of money but i don't understand
it because
they're fixed in the mindset of being in
that business where it's profits over
people
and and also
not just the revenue side of it and the
earnings side of it but people don't
believe that you can have that level of
flexibility that level of innovation
support and and benefits you know as a
business we offer a lot so that's
probably the big one and that's
something that over time i think will
change the more people are talking about
pivot more i do things like this that
some of these people start to think well
it must be true and suddenly as you get
more you know people joining from
businesses they suddenly start to say do
you know what it is true and
it happens and people start talking and
this is almost like a
yeah so obviously yeah that's fair i'm
not surprised by that so people being
cynical about yeah okay sounds great but
is it true but give me some in the
business stuff that's what people would
find useful i think that in the business
stuff um obviously
i think
the tough stuff is the post-covered
world that we've been in
for obviously the first year of the
business we were largely in lockdowns
restrictions and things like that we
went through we became sort of very
routine to structured as individuals so
we'd wake up have our breakfast work
lunch work
back downstairs
to actually get people to really embrace
and use the structure of flexibility you
have to really encourage it you have to
do it yourself to show that it's not
you know a trick
but getting people to use that um but i
think from a management side which i
think is sort of what you really want to
know is i think the big thing that
you've had to learn is you've got to be
adaptable you've got to be flexible but
you've got to go in with a committed
mindset i do want to implement this and
i am going to implement this but
not everything i do is going to work 100
you have to be prepared to constantly
evaluate analyze assess
so and change don't give up on something
because it didn't work first time
and the really important thing is as
you're changing it's really important to
listen to your employees they are the
biggest barometer of whether something
is working or not go to them for ideas
go to them and ask them don't be afraid
to get criticism but you've got to
create a culture and an environment
where if people come back with critical
feedback that is constructive but not
necessarily positive
you can't
you know put a mark against them you've
got to actually go okay i'll take it on
board what do you think we could do to
change it or i think we could do this
what do you think but you've got don't
be afraid to listen to your employees
and stick to what you want to do but
change it and evolve how do you
intentionally do that do you use any
tools or anything like that because it
is that it's one thing to say yeah you
can come and speak to me about
challenges but it's a whole nother thing
people having the courage to say to
their boss that like you know this thing
that you keep doing i'm not a fan of it
like that's dues like tools and
anonymous surveys to get a barometer of
that or use surveys definitely that's a
really good thing
but a massive one is creating that
openness environment where people don't
feel afraid to come and talk to you
about
things you know i constantly will ask
the question
are you okay with this how will you find
things when you're implementing change
specifically ask how are you finding it
some
some people say great it's going really
well but
i think if you create the mentality of
i'm all for you telling me that
something's not working or give me
negative feedback but also throw some
solutions at me don't be a winger be a
be actually somebody who is driving
change
use third party consultancies where
possible you know use independent people
so for example we're about to go through
a massive revamp of our
um benefits package you know what we
offer earnings wise is amazing what we
offer in terms of flexibility innovation
all of that's brilliant but i want our
benefits package to be amazing i want it
to be
you know people wow again asking how can
you do that and there are two key things
that i think are important i'm bringing
in a
workplace well-being
and culture specialist who's going to
run a session with the rest of the
business and myself
coming with ideas
of what benefits would you like to see
don't be afraid to bring a benefit to
the table
but using people to say do you know what
i want an outsider's opinion because
ultimately as a leader you live in a box
yeah
you know the way you evolve and progress
you've got to be willing to let people
in from the outside
and take take on board what they say
they may things may say things that you
don't
you haven't thought off you a different
perspective but
sometimes they then explain it and it's
like yeah that makes sense
so i guess as we come to the end here
just couple things so you we've spoken a
lot about how this could probably help
you
grow your business and hire people but i
guess how how has this approach and this
intention around the business that you
want to build actually manifested in
with your customers with your candidates
like have you also found that obviously
your intention was to be a genuine
different employer but has that actually
ended up then manifesting in the
companies that you speak to um i don't
know and have you have you found that
they're going you know what um because
this is actually a really interesting
approach we like i don't know i'm just
interested if this has also impacted the
commercials of like winning customers
and those things if they've resonated
with what you're trying to build i don't
know how's that played out absolutely i
think from a customer
perspective um
hey
some customers are interested they'll
ask why are you different you know they
look look at the website it's quite
different like how are you different and
they are interested in the fact that
we are booking the trend and sometimes
it aligns with what our clients do we
work with some clients who
themselves are trying to book the trend
in the industry be leaders be be
entrepreneurial and they they're
interested like we want to partner with
a business like you that's also
reflected in our suppliers that we
partner with that they're like we want
to work with you you know you're
actually one of our smaller businesses
but we're really bought into you and
we're not going to treat you as a small
business client we're actually going to
treat you as an enterprise client or a
sme client because do you know what
you're not afraid to try different
things you're not afraid to push us to
the limits in terms of what you can
offer
but i think our clients have also seen a
benefit um in the sense that
the employees the consultants in the
business enjoy working for the business
because they've got a better work life
balance they you know they talk about
the fact that
you know they were doing things they
enjoy they're encouraged to do things
they enjoy at any time in the day it
really doesn't matter they're happier so
they're more motivated when they
actually are working and that's
reflected in the delivery you know we
are
delivering solutions faster and better
to our clients and also the clients are
really benefiting from the innovation
and we've had really really positive
feedback in terms of how we've
integrated video tech innovatively and
i'm not talking about we offer you a
zoom room to do your interviews we've
been doing that for years since covid
started but using videotech to engage
with our candidates our clients
using video tech to add value to
interview processes to make them more
streamlined more effective client
feedback's been phenomenal you know is
really cool you know when you've got a
vp of
a major international oil and gas
business saying that was really cool and
different because
i'd sent a video message to engage with
him i'd utilize video in various parts
of an int well
an assignment and they're telling it's
cool they like it they're seeing the
benefits
we're seeing you know everybody's
suffering from candidate scarcity at the
moment and
we are trying to reach out to candidates
in different ways using tech
and
it's working you know we're not relying
purely on linkedin like a lot of
recruiters we've had candidates engage
with us be and they've said why have you
engaged with us well i'm tired of just
getting linkedin messages but i got i
got this from you and it made me curious
and i wanted to reach out to you so i
did so
it's definitely not just internal
benefits that we're seeing from the way
that we work and we're doing things
ultimately we're seeing external
benefits where our clients our
candidates our companies we partner are
benefiting and
overall what that means is actually the
consultants who are joining us are doing
better than they were in their old place
but they're not working harder longer
hours and that's the reason why it's
actually because
we're innovating we're investing in them
and they're reaping the benefits of that
kazula i think um
look kudos to you to really commit into
this i think it could be very easy to
go back to your old ways
right or just go back to the environment
that you've known for however many years
so yeah definitely just want to say
kudos to you to really commit into that
and i generally feel like hopefully like
more and more
uh recruitment companies can build
environments like this where like you
said they really put as much investment
as they're doing their people as they do
into
growing the bottom line so thank you so
much for joining me i really appreciate
it been an absolute pleasure thank you
really enjoyed being here and really
enjoyed the opportunity of
chatting with you hashem thank you so
much for listening to the episode i hope
you enjoyed it and got value from the
conversation if you did enjoy it please
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you in the next episode